la maison des jeunes et de la culture
marengo d'angoulême reprend vie après
avoir été fermé pendant quelques temps
l'équipe d'animation a décidé de joindre
ses efforts à ceux des autres
responsables des mjc pour en quelque
sorte dynamiser l'action socioculturelle
entreprises angoulême un effort tout
particulier est réalisée au niveau des
très jeunes comme le confirme le
directeur de cette maison des jeunes et
de la culture marc moreau les maisons de
jeunes s'adresse en principe aux
adolescents et aux adultes quelquefois
et je crois que si l'on veut habituer
les jeunes à fréquenter et les maisons
de jeunes
ce n'est pas quand ils ont 15 ou 16 ans
qu'on va leur faire changer leurs
habitudes alors on voudrait les habitués
à y venir avant c'est pourquoi nous
avons créé un certain nombre d'activités
le jeudi après midi qui sont destinés
aux enfants de 7 à 14 ans et même un
petit peu moins activité essentiellement
activités d'expression de création pour
essayer de pallier cette espèce de
d'arrêt brusque des
des facultés d'expression des enfants au
sortir de l'école maternelle on remarque
à l'école maternelle les enfants peuvent
s'épanouir ont des tas de moyens
d'expression que c'est très très
chouette
et puis que arrivée à l'école primaire
bien c'est encore un petit peu bien que
ça a évolué la méthode des bras croisés
alors faudrait les prendre à cet âge là
et puis leur permettre par la peinture
les émaux le mime un tas d'activités
manuelles et les mêmes physique arriver
à le regarder leur moyen d'expression
également sur le plan vocal et ses
matisse est donc volé la dernière fois
il s'est fatigué il sait pas tout cas
la peinture et bien d'autres activités
encore permettront à ces jeunes de
conserver peut-être leur spontanéité
leur fraîcheur et leur imagination
créatrice
et intérieur de cette maison des jeunes
et de la culture que proposez vous comme
activité haute adolescents et bien là on
a un éventail d'activités tout à fait
tout à fait normal ce qui se passe par
rapport à ce qui se passe dans les
maisons de jeunes et de la culture on a
bien sûr une activité photo une activité
danse moderne une activité cinéma une
activité théâtre arts manuels arts
plastiques arts graphiques en tout genre
on a un cours d'espéranto un cours de
sténo on a toujours n'oublie
certainement en particulier pour les
femmes a joué à peine de m rappel de
maintes fois sportivité qui ne rêve pas
qu'il passe le coup d'une heure devant
le problème de cette maison ici précise
la mjc marengo
c'est peut-être de devenir un peu plus
une maison de la culture et des jeunes
qu'une maison des jeunes et de la
culture en ce sens que on est situé ici
au centre d'angoulême dans un quartier
qui n'est plus un quartier c'est à dire
où il n'y a pas vraiment une population
précise on est entouré de commerçants et
d'administration il ya de moins en moins
de gens qui habitent vraiment cet
endroit ce qui fait que on devrait
peut-être s'orienter plus vers une
vocation de deux halls de passage et de
brassage de gens dit des choses à rome
les gens passent où les gens circulent
se rencontrent plutôt qu'un endroit où
des activités très précises ce fonds
très régulièrement
les émaux comme toutes les activités qui
font appel au goût et au sens de la
création artistique connaissent une
grande faveur sur les membres de cette
maison un travail est délicat au terme
duquel on peut obtenir un résultat
intéressant
la mjc du centre un lieu de rencontre
une sorte de carrefour culturel
c'est le but que se sont aussi fixés les
responsables en organisant des
expositions de peintures et de
sculptures
marc moreau vous êtes également le
directeur de la compagnie les tréteaux
d'angoulême
c'est une compagnie qui s'est intégré à
la maison des jeunes et de la culture
est ce que poursuit néanmoins son
activité bien sûr oui la compagnie des
tréteaux d'angoulême est devenu en somme
l'organisme d'animation théâtrale de la
messe de la maison des jeunes et de la
culture de la mjc marengo et elle va
continuer son activité sur deux plans
comme par le passé d'une part studio de
formation d'accueil des nouveaux et de
montage de spectacles légers genre
cabaret café théâtre et recherchent
également et d'autre part réalisation la
compagnie des tréteaux a commencé à
préparer un spectacle
le kkl il s'agit du manteau de gogol
dans une adaptation originale de la
compagnie des tréteaux
les mjc centre d'angoulême possède même
son groupe de recherche instrumental qui
peut être s'il est au point produira un
jour ses oeuvres au festival de musique
contemporaine de royan pourquoi pas